choosing between Pokemon Sun and Moon  can be tough but you might have a third  option before long I'm Tony and this  game spot news update will help you  catch them all Eurogamer has reported on  several nintendo switch rumors and their  latest centers on pokemon multiple  sources have told the site that a third  version of sun and moon is coming to  Nintendo's next console the rumored  project is codenamed Pokemon stars  though personally I think Pokemon  Eclipse sounds a bit cooler in any case  the third version was originally  scheduled for summer 2017 but it's  apparently been pushed back to quote  later in the year we'll see what happens  speaking of the switch will be hearing a  lot more about the console on January  12th when Nintendo tells us all about  the price specs games and launch date  tuning to gamespot for all that info and  for all the latest on pokemon and  nintendo you're already in the right  place  you